e aí
a favela favela senzala moderna sem
pátio na área externa bombril na antena
e saiu de madeira é que poucos enxergam
além da janela lá fora lá fora o mundo
me espera mas ouço da mente cuidado
cuidado o tempo não espera habilidade
dispensas linha chilena sem esquerda ou
direita disciplina exige a coisa certa o
peso da cruz sabe só quem carrega onde a
falta de luz é o pega a brasa da vela
acesa revela pouca simpatia com as
panelas loucas vida esconde o belo da
fera aí desconta na pele mundo moderno
deu quatro rodas ao navio negreiro
vermes aí o bairro do cão é quem dita as
regras eu sou favela lá onde as armas
infelizmente não são de brinquedos 50
e com ela 80 sons que espanta em cada um
dos medos a construção do telhado fez
poucos notaram e as estrelas quantos
vales deixaram morrer o sonho no
travesseiro outros tantos em busca do
seu acorda mais cedo em busca do meu eu
acordei mais cedo nessa em compreendida
fábrica de talentos segue produzindo
artilheiros somos talentos do beco cria
dos campos de lama e trave de chinelo
quantos mandela várias dandara morreram
no corre semianalfabeto na busca das
naves confundimos tempo e dinheiro pouca
opção fez da laje estágio para
fogueteiro a escola recusa a matrícula o
crime deu o primeiro emprego coroa maior
trampo e o velho vive no boteco sem
diploma da escola achei no caderno o
calor duplo esconderam os livros
fornecerá armamentos um pouco
assistência às crianças cresceram na
esquina crescemos sozinho aprendendo que
o
quem sabe assoviar trend verão favela
chorou poesia cantando o segredo nós
cansamos de estar escondidos nos becos
sonhando catar alforria que nunca veio a
utopia à espera que papai noel lembrasse
o nosso endereço peço que o papai do céu
olha por causa guerreiro e por cada
guerreira nessa em compreendida fábrica
de talentos por aqui preto launcher e
hoje a pauta é privilégio embora essa
plateia caucasiana não vem falar dos
seus privilégios vem falar do meu porque
eu me sinto privilegiado de não ter tido
pai e tem sido o criador por duas
guerreiras me sinto privilegiado por
saber antes mesmo de ler o primeiro
livro diferenciar um 38 de um 32 eu me
sinto privilegiado por ter sido
informado pela central única das favelas
saco
e me sinto privilegiado por ter a caneta
o caderno os vinícius como referência
como opção para transformação sou
privilegiado por saber os a dessas
ferramentas para a transformação pessoal
e social e coletiva eu me sinto
privilegiado olha pro lado
e olha para o outro lado poucos negros é
por isso que eu me sinto privilegiado e
não é porque nós não queremos estar
nesse palco
e é porque nós estamos ocupado demais
dividindo cela lotada dividindo neurose
reformatório e com certeza a culpa não é
minha de tudo isso aqui mãos que
apoiaram a escravidão que elegeram que
nos bateya e é por isso que eu me sinto
privilegiado afinal por quantos
professores vocês já tiveram aula por
quantos médicos negros você já foram
atendidos quantos negros subiram no
palco antes de mim
em raros eu sou exceção e o privilégio
meu é ter sido criado por duas
guerreiras tem uma esposa maravilhosa do
jeito que eu tenho uma filha linda que
me ensinou a ser homem e conta isso era
antes das seis e já tava de pé o pão que
o diabo amassou uma olhadinha no café
era antes das seis já tava de pé o pão
que o diabo amassou molhadinho no café
ela enfrentou o espelho à espera e busão
lotado piadinha buzina patrão de
testável odeia o que faz mas mantém
contar paga a chamem de santa afinar o
que faz com o salário é milagre na
mochila coragem coragem coragem coragem
no fone playlist de elza soares antiga
para esses regimento o orgulho da nossa
quebrada a razão dele não o eco da
chibata sincera que
a sandália ela era antes das seis já
tava de pé o pão que o diabo amassou
molhadinho no café essa é minha avó
antes das seis já tava de pé
e o pão que o diabo amassou molhadinho
café ágil seus desejos manias sonhos e
vontades afinal desenhar nas estrelas as
goteiras que ele acordaram depois no
congelador sua expectativa e o
combustível é o abraço dos filhos no
final de tarde bora para o segundo turno
ou a panela não ferve filha sem pai e
mãe solteira sai sem guarda-chuva para
não ser manchete mata no peito a
resposta do sete dos oito dos nove
quanto for preciso não conhece o motivo
para 8 de março muito menos para o
primeiro de maio mas é motivação para os
365 essas são as mulheres que eu conheço
e aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e aí
é muito obrigado lucas se não fosse isso
eu não tava nesse palco hoje muito
obrigado brisa se não fosse eu tinha
desistido no almoço quando não
restaurante for escroto com a gente eu
me sinto privilegiado cara por ter visto
o sol nascer quadrado me sinto
privilegiado por que os dois braços um
dedo e um dente quebrados pela pm quando
a suspeita era um [ __ ] na rua de
baixo e eu os bolso igual a minha
carteira vazia sem flagrante eu me sinto
privilegiado por tá nessa nesse palco
afinal em pleno século 21 diariamente
perdemos 23 532 viram estrelas cadentes
jovens como biadi tão cedo quanto
mariele por motivos como do amarildo
flagrante com cor de pele os vermes
mostra não e quanto
e ainda sofrem com silêncio censura e
sirene bandido bom eleitor voto virar
troca de interesses é o preço que
pagamos por valores invertidos juros
corrigidos vem trocar de bala e
antecipar a partida de quem nem tinha
passagem por aqui balas perdidas tem
endereço certo sabia e ainda vive de
aluguel servindo camarão e almoçando
miojo nessa briga de classe e sujas
órgãos de uma pátria podre e os boy me
diz calma launcher experimentar na minha
pé
o experimento da tá na minha pele dar um
rolê no shopping e
e aí